THE DOW GAINED 241.
THE S&P 500 FINISHED AHEAD 18.
THE NASDAQ WAS UP 34.
AMAZON IS UNDER INCREASING
SCRUTINY FROM PRESIDENT TRUMP AS
WE HAVE BEEN SAYING.
HE ACCUSES THE ONLINE RETAILER
OF BILKING AMERICANS BY ABUSING
THE U.S. POSTAL SERVICE.
TONIGHT, CORRESPONDENT
GILLIAN TURNER TELLS US HE COULD
BE GETTING CLOSE TO A CHANGE IN
THAT ARRANGEMENT.
>> THE POST OFFICE IS LOSING
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND THE
TAXPAYERS ARE PAYING FOR THAT
MONEY BECAUSE IT DELIVERS
PACKAGES FOR AMAZON ADS ARE VERY
BELOW COST.
>> THE MUCH-MALIGNED DEAL
BETWEEN USPS AND AMAZON HAS BEEN
IN PLACE FOR FIVE YEARS AND IT'S
SET TO EXPIRE IN OCTOBER.
NOW TECH INSIDERS TELL FOX NEWS
THAT NEW LEADERS APPOINTED BY
THE PRESIDENT HIMSELF MAY SOON
TAKE THE REINS AT THE STRUGGLING
AGENCY AND DETERMINE THE DEAL'S
FATE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S NOMINATED
THREE PEOPLE TO THE USPS BOARD
OF GOVERNORS.
THE EXECUTIVE BODY THAT OVERSEES
ALL ITS MAJOR DECISIONS.
THEY ARE CALVIN TUCKER, CHAIRMAN
OF THE PHILADELPHIA BLACK
REPUBLICAN COUNCIL.
ROBERT DUNCAN, CHAIRMAN OF THE
PRESIDENT'S COMMISSION ON
WHITE HOUSE FELLOWSHIP.
AND DAVID WILLIAMS, FORMER
INSPECTOR GENERAL FOR USPS.
IF THESE NOMINEES ARE CONFIRMED
BY THE SENATE LATER THIS MONTH,
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S VIEWS ON
AMAZON WILL BE FRONT AND CENTER.
>> THEY WOULD BE THREE PEOPLE
APPOINTED BY TRUMP IN A POSITION
OF AUTHORITY AND POWER TO SAY TO
THE SALES DEPARTMENT, HEY, WE
WANT YOU TO TAKE A MORE
STRATEGIC LOOK AT THIS AMAZON
CONTRACT.
>> EXPERTS CAUTION THAT A BETTER
DEAL WITH AMAZON WON'T FIX THE
POSTAL SERVICE'S LARGER
PROBLEMS.
>> THE POSTAL SERVICE HAS BEEN
IN A CRISIS SINCE ABOUT 1995.
THEY'VE BEEN LOSING MONEY FOR
YEARS AND YEARS.
>> THE COUPLE TO HAVE THE
CRISIS?
THE RISE OF THE INTERNET.
AMERICANS PREFERENCE FOR
COMMUNICATING BY EMAIL.
IN JUST A DECADE, BETWEEN 2002
AND 2012, FIRST CLASS LETTER
DELIVERY IN THE U.S. DROPPED BY
ALMOST 30%.
FROM 102.4 BILLION PIECES OF
MAIL WHICH ONLY 73.5 BILLION.
AND IN THE FIRST QUARTER OF THIS
YEAR ALONE, LETTER VOLUME
BUT DESPITE THIS DISMAL PICTURE,
EXPRESS IDENTIFY ONE BRIGHT SPOT
ON THE HORIZON, PACKAGES.
>> THE GROWING PART OF THE
POST OFFICE BUSINESS IS PERSONAL
DELIVERY.
AND THE SHRINKING PART
CONTINUING TO SHRINK OF THE
POST OFFICE AS BUSINESSES FIRST
CLASS MAIL.
>> EVEN IF PACKAGES CONTINUE TO
PICK UP, USPS BASIS OF OTHER
FINANCIAL BURDENS, COURTESY OF
CONGRESS.
2006    2006 REQUIRES A LOCKED O
2006    2006 REQUIRES A LOCKED N
2006    2006 REQUIRES A LOCKED M
2006    2006 REQUIRES A LOCKED Y
POSTAL SERVICE TO PREFUND HEALTH
BENEFITS FOR THE RETIRED